la publicité urbaine au coeur d'une
réunion publique ce lundi 12 novembre
saint quentin en yvelines a présenté à
cette occasion ses premiers travaux sur
son futur règlement local de publicité
intercommunale c'est un texte important
pour le cadre de vie des habitants et
donc je devais aussi concerner
l'ensemble des acteurs que ce soit les
habitants les acteurs économiques ou les
acteurs qui milite pour la protection de
l'environnement pour essayer d'avoir un
texte finalement qui soit équilibrée et
et qui convienne à tout le monde
plusieurs axes ont été proposées au
cours de cette soirée pour encadrer
cette publicité urbaine à l'horizon 2020
les objectifs sont clairs réduire le
format publicitaire sur le territoire
avec la proposition qui est faite
de passer de 12 m² à 8 mètres carrés
pour ce qui concerne la publicité c'est
une proposition qui est en cours de
discussion c'est aussi la volonté
d'imposer des règles de densité qui
seraient plus stricts que la
réglementation nationale
malgré ces propositions certains
habitants présents dans la salle reste
sceptique sur ce futur règlement et ont
pu faire part de leurs inquiétudes
très clairement notre plus grosse
crainte et puis on l'a vu ce soir il ya
eu beaucoup de commentaires là dessus
c'est les écrans numériques car nouveau
type de dispositif publicitaire très
agressif et énergivore en plus dont
l'implantation apparemment et tourner
quand même sur beaucoup de zones sur
l'agglomération
d'autant plus que les dimensions même si
on va à les réduire pour tout ce qui est
affichage a dû 12 m par du 8 mètres
carrés
lassana sous-tend qu'on va pouvoir
implanter des écrans numériques de 8
mètres carrés disque est énormissime les
dossiers de concertation sont
disponibles dans l'es12 mairies de
l'agglomération vous avez jusqu'au 1er
semestre 2010 9 pour donner votre avis